facebook is biased against facts and
against journalism and this harms
democracy that's the message from 2021
nobel peace prize joint winner maria
ressa an investigative journalist from
the philippines she has seen firsthand
the impact of the gradual erosion of
journalistic freedoms in her country in
fact under president rodrigo duterte the
philippines has fallen further in
international press freedom rankings
than ever before you'll hear what maria
ressa has to say about that in a moment
but first this report
an attack on independent media a total
war against journalists this is how the
news landscape is described in the
philippines
since president rodrigo duterte was
elected in 2016 the country has been
sliding down the press freedom index
and she is leading the fight against it
maria ressa and her news site rappler
have emerged as key voices against
duterte's regime
the nobel committee has recognized that
ms resa
and rappler have documented how social
media is being used to spread fake news
harass opponents
and manipulate the public discourse
it's a job not without risk the
philippines consistently ranks among the
top 10 deadliest countries for
journalists
reports say as many as 19 of them have
been killed since duterte took office
deaths which don't seem to phase the
leader
at news of one he replied just because
you're a journalist you are not exempted
from assassination if you're a son of a
perhaps it's because journalists have
played a key role in scrutinizing
duterte's controversial war on drugs
which has reportedly seen some 12 000
people killed at the hands of security
forces
families of the dead are relying on
journalists to hold them accountable
despite the risks and legal challenges
brought by the government the nobel
laureate is optimistic
you know i sometimes i joke and i say
i should really thank president duterte
for a lot of things he's forced me to
define my lines he's forced me to stick
to the idea of my values
he's forced rappler to be
more idealistic better faster
more mission driven and i hope
you know
we come out of it stronger
it's a promise ressa has kept to so far
as she inspires journalists and those
fighting for democracy across the world
and i'm joined now by ceo of digital
news outlet rappler.com an investigative
journalist herself and now joint winner
of the nobel peace prize for 2021 maria
reza maria firstly
many many congratulations from everyone
here at dw news it is such a pleasure to
be speaking to you
today thank you for having me thank you
now it's it's nearly two weeks since you
were announced a joint winner dad i
asked has life changed for you since
then
it's become doubly busy but i think also
the the other part is this it's been an
incredible shock of adrenaline and
energy for journalists in the
philippines and
uh the last week or so i've been talking
to journalists in other parts of the
world who
i mean many of them have it worse than
we do so it just emphasized how much
more difficult it is to do our jobs and
it's something that the norwegian nobel
committee also alluded to in fact while
making the award it said freedom of
expression is a court precondition for
democracy and lasting peace
do you think that most ordinary people
in the philippines where you work would
see it that way
i believe so and you know part of what
we saw the weekend after was this
tremendous outpour i mean i felt the
love you know and it's that that is so
rare on social media given that that is
the vector that is the place where
rappler and i and journalists here have
been attacked but it was like a weekend
of love and that reminded me of where of
the good that social media can do over
the past so many years and we've talked
about this in the past as well the fact
is that many people in your country have
seen you as a part of the problem you
know as someone who's going up against a
popular leader in this case rodrigo
duterte who at least is perceived to be
doing good for their country i wonder
therefore what do you tell people like
that why is independent journalism
important for them as well
i think this is what the nobel committee
just highlighted right that facts are at
the core
of any democracy that freedom of speech
freedom of expression is about being
able to say what you think without fear
of retribution um and then you know i'll
do a i'll just spotlight that popularity
easily turns into mob rule but in the
age of social media you can't quite tell
whether it's real or manufactured
and do you think social media therefore
has a very important role to play and
potentially the gatekeepers of social
media have a vastly more important role
than they acknowledge to play in the
proper functioning of democracies
i think that the rollback of democracy
globally and the tearing apart of the
shared reality has has been it's because
of tech it's because news organizations
lost our gatekeeping powers to
technology and technology
took the
revenues that we used to have you know
along with um
they took the powers but they abdicated
responsibility and i think this is is a
wake-up call and that's happening not
just for journalists with the nobel with
the nobel spotlight but also you are
seeing many more sophisticated
discussions about what exactly is wrong
that we're moving finally away from
content moderation
to
where we should be which is algorithmic
distribution algorithmic amplification
and how it has insidiously manipulated
human beings on the platform you have
you have been at facebook you have been
a part of many panels at facebook that
has looked at just things like these and
i mentioned facebook because it is very
popular in the in the philippines what
would you like to see happen with big
tech like facebook
i think the core of the problem is that
all the social media platforms treat
lies and facts identically they're data
points right and and the research has
now shown us that on social media
lies laced with anger and hate spread
faster and further than facts so you can
say that the world's largest delivery
platform of news
is actually biased against facts and
bias against journalism and as a result
of that fundamental choice that the tech
platforms have made we have
cheap armies on social media rolling
back democracy in 81 countries around
the world that is from oxford
university's computational propaganda
research project so
it's i think so here's the other thing
that dawned on me that the last time a
journalist was given this honor was in
1936
he wasn't able to go accept the honor in
person in oslo because he was in a nazi
concentration camp he languished in in a
nazi concentration camp and so i think
that's the signal that the nobel
committee is telling us again that we
are kind of
at this existential moment where we
could lose our rights we could lose
democracy if we lose the facts
right
i'd like to sort of switch a bit to talk
about the leader
of the philippines i mean you are no
stranger to facing flak from the
government of president rodrigo duterte
i wonder any personal message of
congratulations from him
no none i mean you know it took three
days i was actually i was actually
saying that um
that uh the russia that that president
putin and the kremlin congratulated
dmitry uh the same day and it took maybe
three days before the presidential
spokesman
gave a grudging congratulations to the
first filipino but then turned it around
and said the prize is
is evidence that press freedom is alive
and well in the philippines yes in fact
we'd like to sort of play what harry
roque the presidential spokesman said of
your nobel prize of course he also said
at the very outset that it's a i quote
it's a victory for a filipina and we are
very happy for that this is what he went
on to say
it is not a slap in the government it
was made by private individuals
in norway we respect their decision but
as i said criminal liability of maria
resa remains spending in our courts and
we leave it to our courts to decide on
her faith
there is no slap there because as
as everyone knows
no one has ever been censored in the
philippines
maria no one has been
censored in the philippines how true is
that
you see my smile
let me put it this way
you know uh the largest broadcaster in
the philippines
is off the air
and the last time that happened was when
martial law was declared in 1972
you've had at least 19 journalists
killed under this administration
you have a journalist who's 23 years old
languishing in prison for more than a
year
and you know of course i've had 10
arrest warrants in less than two years
so
sometimes all you have to do is smile we
have an election coming up
uh next year maria and you talked about
that a little earlier
why should we be concerned about this
election how important is it
why are these elections important
because you know this is really the
battle for facts
you go to this we've been in 2016 we
we demanded an end to impunity of
rodrigo duterte and the drug war and
mark zuckerberg and facebook
35 years after the marcos family was was
tossed out of the philippines by a
people power revolt
ferdinand marcos jr bongbong marcos
now has is running for president so you
know in 2019 rappler actually exposed
the networks of disinformation that had
been created to chip away at history to
reorient history and i can share that i
can share the links with you but you
know this is going to be a battle for
facts and we're going to have to make
sure that facts win and in order to do
that these american social media
platforms are going to have to put guard
rails and prioritize facts maria erisa
it's also a privilege talking to you
maria risa the joint winner of the nobel
peace prize for 2021 thank you so much
for taking time out for us today
you